the battle between the strongest
continues with tsukuna pulling off some
unbelievable Feats and actually having
Gojo feeling like he might lose for once
and then Gojo's unbelievable response
with his strongest hidden power yet
we're talking world ending power the
hype is off the charts unlimited one
might say so many of our questions are
answered from last chapter so make sure
to stay tuned for this epic chapter use
your six eyes to locate and smash that
like button if you enjoy Jujutsu Kaizen
reviews like this one I want to keep
them coming on the channel and make this
the video you joined the special grade
fan by subscribing and hitting that
notification Bell so you don't miss
future Jutsu Kaizen videos you have the
power to help us hit our insane goal of
2 million subscribers here on YouTube by
just pushing one button and now without
further Ado let's jump into the hypest
fight of hypus fights spoilers and all
last chapter ended up with insane twist
after insane twist Gojo landed a black
flash that finally seemed to knock sukun
out for good his eyes went white and
everything the maharaga wheel fell but
then it spun in mahuraga appeared
attacking Gojo he slashed Gojo showing
that he had indeed finally adapted to
Gojo's infinity and Gojo is now in
trouble another question we had which
will be answered in this chapter is if
maharaga adapted to all of the Limitless
or just the techniques kojo used so far
and if sukuna is still combat ready even
after it looked like he was taken out of
commission last chapter so now with
those questions in mind let's jump into
this chapter chapter 233 this chapter
starts with everyone being
understandably worried about maharaga
but Yuji is still hopeful saying that
even if mahuraga adapted to Infinity
it's still on equal footing with Gojo
and Gojo's wounds can be healed soon I
just also love how we always see Yuta
freaking out and sweating I feel like
the mangaka thinks Utah has the perfect
face for it or something like that
because we see his word expression all
the time during this fight but then back
to Eugene you gotta love yuji's optimism
and he brings up a solid Point Gojo's
Infinity being taken out just puts him
where most Fighters would start out with
anyway and Gojo is still the strongest
sorcerer after that however he's also
been going for a long time now with his
domain expansions reverse curse
technique after reverse curse technique
whether in the form of healing or red so
even he one would think might be
reaching his limit accordingly we see a
highly stressed shoko who has smoked a
lot of cigarettes mind you to show how
worried she is chain smoking the whole
time she says Gojo's healing speed is
getting slow and she would know as a
reverse cursed expert herself she says
Gojo can use reverse curse technique
since we saw him use his red ability a
little while ago but the output is
decreasing even Gojo is running out of
steam it seems clear right now but at
least she points out that it should be
the same for sukura the only problem is
sukuna's load is being shared by the
overpowered chikigami mahuraga as well
so I can't imagine it being as difficult
as it is for Gojo even if sukuna wins it
definitely feels a bit like he's
cheating here not just just relying on
his own powers but then again when has
that ever bothered bad guys and a win is
a win at the end of the day Gojo for his
part seems to feel the same way and has
never thought to complain but only to
rise up to every subsequent challenge
which is why we love and respect them
and by the way we also love and respect
people who hit that subscribe button if
you haven't already but then we see
something truly crazy the narrator says
that again we'll get clear translations
when the actual official translated
Pages come out but the narrator says
even if opponent is strongest of all
time the king of curses everyone thought
it was impossible they thought Gojo
might lose even Gojo himself thought so
that's an insane Revelation right now
because when it comes to talking Gojo's
always sure of himself like he always
seems super confident like there's no
doubt in his mind but here we see that
in his thoughts even he has his doubts
that makes this fight all the more
intense and Epic no matter what happens
here we can't look back and say Gojo had
complete control of this fight the whole
time in fact we get a cool shout out to
the season being animated right now as
Gojo thinks when was the last time he
felt like this and toji immediately pops
up in his mind remember he did lose to
toji before in the end toji forced his
Evolution and he became a much stronger
fighter but before that toji beat him in
round one so again Gojo probably feels
like sukun and mahuraga have him on the
ropes now but that begs the question
will that just push him to reach and
unlock another level of power like after
toji had him on the ropes as well either
way the narrator makes it clear that
Gojo is not worried or scared in fact
it's quite the opposite even though
signs that he might lose are coming up
something is swelling up more in Gojo
and it is satisfaction in caps by the
way so a lot of satisfaction the
loneliness that comes from being the
strongest again comes up and I've been
mentioning this throughout the chapters
Gojo has been loving this fight because
it finally helped with that loneliness
and now the mangakas emphasizing it in
black and white again Gojo has been
longing for something like this for a
fight where he too could possibly lose I
love to see good guys and not just bad
guys being capable of this kind of
badass mindset it's like getting excited
by The Challenge and the possibility of
losing more than just the certainty of
Victory Gojo then starts treating
maharaga like a human opponent which is
crazy in and of itself he quickly
punches maharaga on the face and pushes
it back making mahuraga choke against
this shikigami that's that's insane like
that's insane to even think about Gojo
then recites the chance to restore his
lowered output and proceeds to blast
curse technique reversal red but sukuna
has regained Consciousness and activates
megumi's rabbit Escape technique Gojo's
blast damages the surroundings but
mahuraga escapes and Gojo realizes that
sukuna is protecting maharaga and using
it for offense since it has adapted to
Gojo's Infinity that's another crazy
idea someone supporting and assisting a
monster like but credit to sukuna for
thinking of it and credit to Gojo for
being so ridiculously strong that he
actually makes something like that
necessary it's not just rabbitsukuna
uses to the strike Gojo but also a fire
extinguisher that creates a smoke screen
mahuraga attacks from overhead while
sukuna strikes the pose that choso uses
for piercing blood Gojo then does
complain according to these spoilers a
big deal for Gojo to be sure about
sukuna being able to use shikigami
abilities without even having to summon
them turns out the last attack was a
water shoe technique from Max elephant
shikigami but he used piercing blood
method to increase the power and
concentration of the blast crazy how
sukuna never ceases to impress and pull
more things from his sleeves even Gojo
is like come on man at this point just
as Gojo is defending against mahoraga
sukuna lands his attack on Gojo's arm
and wounds him goju realizes it's not
just about tsukuna supporting maharaga
anymore who can wound Gojo when mahoraga
makes contact he deactivates Gojo's
infinity and then sukuna can also attack
so now it's pretty much two versus one
or at least it seems like that but not
for long Gojo's expression actually
looks Siri is now he's not all smiles as
usual he thinks to himself that adapting
to Red will take more time compared to
Blue now whether this is because red is
a reverse curse technique of blue and
thus more complicated or because Gojo
just hasn't used it as much as blue in
this battle I'm not sure if it comes
down to complication though then
hopefully Gojo has some more insane and
complicated abilities that he's saving
for maharaga and sukuna down the line
but just as Gojo has already got to the
point where he's serious sukuna says
don't misunderstand it's not two versus
one but three versus one and he summons
a new shikigami named Chimera Beast
agito this seems to allow him to combine
different shikigami into a mega
shikigami as the spoilers point out it
seems to merge nue in totality but
sukuna didn't specifically say merge but
just chanted these two names first in
the last page and then summoned this new
one either way the dude is showing
insane Mastery over this technique which
he recently got from megumi's body it's
unreal so now it's this new overpowered
chickigami and maharaga and sukuna vs
one go Dojo three versus one so sukuna
was just rubbing it and saying oh you
only think it's that bad no bro it's way
worse than you think after Gojo
dominated most of the fight up to this
point the tables have turned and in this
chapter sukuna is crushing it crazy how
quick he went from being knocked out to
winning it's comforting to see that Gojo
hasn't lost his sense of humor though
and even though he's in a tricky
situation he teases sukuna saying that
between these two giants he looks like a
Lost Child also implying that he can't
win on his own and needs the help of his
quote unquote parents to bail him out
everyone then attacks Gojo at the same
time he's doing an amazing job dodging
and even gets a shot off at maharaga but
the red blast doesn't do any meaningful
damage at all at first Gojo's expression
is almost of disbelief but then he
smiles again as we're used to it seems
clear that maharaga has adapted to Red
enough that Gojo can't hope to beat it
with red that or it's not even strong
enough in the first place so Gojo thinks
he now only has quote unquote that to
demolish maharaga in one shot again the
mangaka is so good at building suspense
and intensity here before it was four
turns and now it comes down to one shot
Gojo thinks that the charge is big and
sukuna will be aware of it but he says
he has no other choice but to use it so
there he goes hyping up his secret power
that in of itself is crazy he seems to
be even unsure if it'll work but he's in
a corner and he has no other options
crazy we saw the day where Gojo is in
such a position but this is a Shonen
battle manga and you can bet he'll pull
off this insane technique called an
unlimited Holo Technique we know that
Hollow is purple the combining of red
and blue and something maharaga
shouldn't have adapted to yet because
Gojo hasn't been using purple beyond
that though we can assume that it will
be a new power a new purple attack one
we haven't seen yet Gojo's most powerful
technique of all and in all likelihood
his ultimate finisher move and wow I
think this was the best chapter of the
fight yet let me know if you agree and
if you think Gojo will be able to pull
off the victory with this final ultimate
technique crazy to see him push to a
corner like this at all if you want to
know more about the monster who pushed
Gojo to his limit then make sure to
check out our recent video about why
everyone is afraid of sukuna link on
screen right now and don't forget to
like And subscribe and help us get to 2
million subscribers